what up everybody homies how you livin
how you feeling how you doing is the LEF
koe man it is July 4th week I hope you
guys are somewhere warm somewhere with a
grill somewhere enjoying life too
awesome podcast this week this one as
you saw in the description Mena Kimes of
ESPN awesome conversation we talked
about her top 5 Seattle Seahawks of all
time
she made a purring noise when Patrick
mahomes his name came up and we broke
down the possible teams that are being
overlooked for competing for a Super
Bowl really in-depth football
conversation when you're talking to Mena
she can handle it so it was a lot of fun
she's awesome
so go support her and please hit her up
on social media Twitter Instagram and
tell her thank you for coming in and
hanging out to 33% because I'd like her
to come back again I want to give a
shout out before we get to the mediacom
show by the way I'm recording the intro
no music I want to get done the intro
we're gonna crank out another bit of
advertising and then get to the show so
there's less advertising when you're
listening to the show but a shout out to
the two homies that won the eat like a
homie challenge for 33 days leave O and
shine slime I talked to travell Gaines
about you guys losing 25 pounds and
really pack it on some muscle to here's
what we're gonna do I'm gonna be very
honest with you we could not pay for
flight we cannot pay for room and board
I'm just being honest okay that's it was
sort of an agreement we didn't talk
about it but travell told me that if
you're able to get out there he can he
can support you he's gonna cover your
meals he's gonna train you like a
professional everything that his guys
get the meals the training all that
he'll cover he'll even cover some gear
for you that he's gonna talk to some
brands about outfitting you guys if
you're able to get out there to LA he's
got you for a week for meals gear and
professional training if you can't know
that you're already a legend and I'm
gonna work with travel to get that gear
sent to you so at least you're gonna
have some stuff to work out and all that
so my two guys shines line and of course
leave o if you're able to make it we
can't cover room and board
or travel travel we'll take care of you
guys so you're the man and everyone that
did the 33 days of eating like a homie
you're the best also so without further
ado let us get to the lady the queen bee
of the NFL right after this
advertisement Minah Kimes
[Music]
that giggle as Minah Kimes let's go I
put the odds of you freestyling at about
forty to one have you have that
freestyle in your I'll go a little bit
higher than forty two one yeah in your
life
yes actually was this yeah so you know
the punter Marquette King of course the
cool putter the fun punter for a minute
injured I think he's planning to come
back he's a good punter yeah as well
play with Gruden couldn't be there
anymore yes yes and then I think he did
a video of himself punting a Chucky doll
right after that which was a move I
respected I was in a car with him taping
something a couple years ago and he and
his friends started freestyling and
there was immense pressure on me to do
it how many bars did you get out uh
about four lines that's usually all you
have to do well is to if you really the
first one to the second one and no one's
expecting you to freestyle that will get
the oh I got it I got a she knows how to
rhyme to words yeah I got a very Rory
Asst oh it was because I was like
sweating through my I was so tense and
I'm so uncool you know I don't know rap
I don't know what's new I don't know
anything I will say this though I got a
little frustrated today because I was
walking around the office and they were
like so who's coming in later I was like
Mina Kimes and everyone's like I really
like her a lot I don't know anyone that
doesn't like you and so it frustrated me
there are people I encourage you to
search the internet search the mention
search the mentees man big-time Seattle
Seahawks fan you are what is your
official title at ESPN senior writer Wow
yeah but he I'm writing a little bit
less these days yeah been a little bit
more I'm seeing you on High Noon I'm
seeing you I have not seen you on first
take I seen you on around the horn
I do not forsake Wow oh yeah I've
dropped the takes not but I wasn't
debating max or gosh certainly not
Steven I you were actually bringing
content well that I it was we were like
the I don't even think I'm the first
take B team I think I'm like the D team
nice so it was a it's been like the heat
either the the dead of summer or I think
Christmas I feel like I did Christmas
and you had me on your podcast Amina
kind of show with I did I appreciate
that very are our listeners loved you
you know what I love them and 33 percent
I need you to show meaning the same type
of love so get into her mentions and if
you see anyone in her mentions with the
[ __ ] fight them for her that's what
we're gonna do we're gonna it's gonna be
a little mote your background to me is
wild because sports to me is this like
jokey means nothing world and you are in
finance and how you got here is really
interesting so you go to Yale and the
whole time are you thinking I want to do
financial reporting was that that's
where the plan no I didn't really know
what I wanted to do but I kind of
stumbled into this internship at fortune
so I just ended up working there so
knowledge you went to an internship
everybody probably liked you you're
probably very proficient at your job and
like any young person they offer you a
gig you take it yes to have a job in New
York out of college was a thrill yes
quite quite an unexpected thing coming
from Arizona I went to high school and
desperately wanting to live very far
from Arizona school so I did that for a
few years became an investigative
journalist I read about Wall Street did
investigative journalism for a while
went to Bloomberg News work for Business
Week stressful as an investigator always
stressful it's so stressful like it was
there any moments where you were like I
cannot believe I'm doing this right now
sometimes it's funny now when like an
athlete's rap is angry because
you like use the wrong shoe Brad I don't
know thinking back to when lawyers were
like threatening to sue me for writing
about health care fraud or things that
were let's just say a lot more impacted
her impacting like lines and revenue
streams but I did that for a few years
and then but the whole time I was quite
a sports fans football mainly yeah and
was mostly just tweeting dumb because on
the spot of course mostly just tweeting
dumb [ __ ] about sports and then I wrote
a little thing for slate about football
and ESPN right it was like hey you might
you seem to like this more than how do
the mergers and acquisitions your
mentions doing finance compared to
sports well so that yeah you know I
didn't have like a huge following it's
not it's nothing like sports Twitter
like Twitter's is not yeah I mean the
other thing is like my now my social
life social media life other guys
conflate them one of the sadly is um
it's very different from when I started
a yes yeah because I started as a writer
and so as a writer I wasn't really
public facing you're just putting your
stories and that's it you know I go on
TV sometimes on OTL or whatever about my
cover story on Darrelle Revis or what
have you but since I started doing more
talking it's I get a lot more talking
back what's really funny is I think
you're really good on TV
but I don't think that you are sure
about it sometimes and I'm like for me
being able to have actual conversations
with context and not just to in the take
machine is where I think we're finally
getting to we're seeing through all that
crap and I I've said this to you so many
times I just want full-fledged Mina home
yeah like I want it don't take that out
of context people yeah I thank you I
appreciate that I will say in defense of
the tech machine I I what it's it's
entertaining and also though I think
it's good to have takes and it's good
like in a I presume they we're gonna
have a conversation about football today
and not about me but it would be pretty
boring if we were just like
but he's a great guy you know or like
yeah but you know like true like
sometimes I think criticism and opinions
make these conversations more
interesting to me all right so I don't
know if you know that we do this
whoa big offseason which really is the
stories that we've all read about our
teams and you see the headline and it
becomes a thing but it's really not that
big of a deal I have a few and I want to
run them by you and I need you to tell
me if they're whoa or whoa it's actually
big okay okay can you do that well in
the world for me again whoa that's a
fake like come on
or whoa okay okay so you don't go on
this yeah you're gonna hear one and then
you're gonna take it the wrong way and I
will have given the wrong inflection to
the world
Seahawks rookie wide receiver DK
Metcalfe is picking up the offense
quickly well I mean every rookie wide
receiver I know I am to be clear
extremely overhyped on d gaben the rest
of us are going interesting Seattle
Russell can get in the pocket DK if he's
able to stretch the defense like it
could be interesting but then there's
the other side where I watch him the
chop steps go like five yards too far
where should Seattle fans be with their
hype towards DK Metcalf I think they
should be really excited for a couple
reasons one Doug's retired da Baldwin so
the Seahawks actually need he's not a
luxury for them they actually need him
to be a weapon to yes as we saw during
the combine and you know he didn't have
that much production some of that was
due to injury in college he's not the
greatest most sophisticated runner yet
yet but I do think some of that can be
attributed to college and the particular
scheme he came from but also the
Seahawks don't really need him to do
that yet because there are two things
he's very good at one is being very very
fast and going deep and Russell Wilson
is one of the best deep ball throws the
NFL and just that you don't play action
Russell go deep Raymond our baby break
it off hey when our baby boy Tyler
Lockett cut that connects
is it for those who don't know I don't
even why is he our be this weird thing
we started one time DMing about Tyler
Lockett and then you said that your mom
calls him her boy all right Nick me from
his doll baby don't like the weirdest
imagine a 70 year old Korean woman
calling a football player doll baby
screaming so then every time Tyler
Lockett would have a touchdown we would
just like diem be like baby there he is
yeah so so he's great and then too I my
hope and my I think belief is that
they're gonna use him the way they did
Jimmy Graham who was never he was never
what he was in New Orleans and he was in
Seattle but by the end of his time there
he became a touchdown machine because
they would just frickin post him up like
DeAndre Jordan and he was just reach up
and grab the ball so my thinking is that
potentially DK could be that as well as
yet I will say though that Russell in
this article talking about how
intelligent DK Metcalfe is I never know
if they're trying to give those guys
confidence through the media or if
that's how they actually feel I can
never figure it out well you know
Russell Wilson is normally so honest and
cynical and transparent all right let's
go into that before I get to the next
one this has been the summer of Russell
Wilson oh boy we have seen a complete
transition yo-yo Seattle what's going on
that is impeccable yo it's time he
oughta go to sleep with the chains we
seen this hair getting braided he's at
the Yankees game like just chillin post
enough it's been incredible for me to
watch someone that I have thought was
like so manicured and so corny super
dorky do this Stephon Oracle change to
the Russell but is this all Ciara
like what do we attribute this to I have
so many thoughts about this first but
first and foremost I'm thrilled yes I
want to look he's a very embarrassing
human being
an embarrassing human being that if a
cheetah was rushing towards him I would
use my body as a human shield to protect
like he that's how much he has been a
source of so much I mean years of fant
before him it was tar Varis Jackson like
I mean obviously pastor Beck was just
saying you know how it is when you get
the guy as a fan and as soon as he got
there it was a new era defend him to the
death yes obviously yeah it's pre 2012
post-2012 my life is two periods that's
all so first I only saw in black and
white now I see in color but I think
yeah I don't know enough about Russell
I've never interviewed him to speak to
kind of like the influences his life if
his friends his relationships obviously
CRI it's pretty undeniable she's had an
influence on him at least stylistically
right right but one thing I and I think
you can probably speak to this as well
one thing I've learned from being around
NFL players and interviewing them and
spending time with them is they leave on
the lead unusual lives some of them are
not exposed to a diversity of and I'm
not just speaking racially I just like
of people from the country or the city
or people with different educational
backgrounds like most of us go to
college or not most of us but some of us
are we moved to a city or we or suddenly
and we become different people I was
very different when I was 23 from how I
was when I was 19 I think a lot of times
with athletes that process is a little
bit delayed even Aaron Rodgers and I
spoke about this I did a story about him
a couple years ago he himself told me
he's like I started changing as a person
when I was in my late 20s right because
you know you live this really weird
sheltered life and so I your schedule is
done for totally you're at all why are
you interacting with people in the
public they can hurt you don't yeah
right so you have a very small circle so
I need I think one thing you just see a
lot with athletes is I don't wanna call
it delayed development because that
sounds weird and kind of reductive but I
think delayed exposure may be to certain
things and it feels like that's a thing
it does feel like with this whole
Russell Wilson thing that I think at
Oracle are kids exactly he it it's kind
of beautiful to watch him grow like it
it's it's kind of great
like for a while he was always the guy
we're given 110 percent I drink this
water it helps with concussions like
there was a lot of I don't really know
what this person is all about right the
rest of the team the legion of boom
saying like you're not really one of us
like that was the other dynamic for a
while with Seattle and I also wondered
was it this perfect mix of Ciara coming
in and opening up this whole new world
but also the legion of boom is
completely gone yes there is no other
King in the locker room anymore and now
that Doug's gone to know Doug no Sherman
no kam no Earl yeah now Russell's the
man I mean he so I don't know if it's
both of those things together he's also
just a lot older than everyone there now
and that's what happened that's another
thing that turnover of a locker Rodgers
and I talked about I remember it very
vividly because his MO is like a weird
flex that I keep it Frank you know I'm
not gonna interrupt it's because we're
talking about quarterback and you know
I've been around some quarterbacks and
butBut he was describing to me his
experience of like guys leaving the team
and and young guys coming in I was like
oh okay I get it you know they keep
getting younger and used to same age and
he's like yeah it is that he got the
reference fortunately perfect otherwise
that would have seemed really weird but
um it courted the quarterback is an
unusual position that way for sure your
friends leave and you're still there and
I think Russell becoming like the
veteran and the older statesman the
locker room has probably helped his
confidence and they've been able to
build that team around him I will say
about the Legion of boom a little bit of
Seahawks insider ISM I guess but you
know whenever there were like negative
stories coming around the defense versus
Russell it was just one member of each
one know Bennett's not in the Legion of
is it also by the way Michael Bennett
likes you've responded how he likes
Russell Wilson yeah we spoken up tell us
was not a fan when I asked him about it
yeah Michael actually has praised him a
lot and he praised him in as much
Richard yeah okay yeah I'm who cares
yeah no I was just saying like it's
funny that you became the whole
everybody you know everybody you know
he's got a legs he's great who are Mena
Kimes top five Seattle Seahawks of all
time of all like my personal personal
five nine like I got asked this for the
Eagles and it my first list had like
Chuck Bednarik in it and my one friend
said to me that's like when people put K
Rs 1 and their top 5 rappers one hipster
answer and it's it's there's a reason
for it right so 5 is it will go 5 to 1
okay
Marshawn Lynch ok number 4 no question
you know ya old Thomas number 3 and a
lot of new era ones um Cortez Kennedy
that's not a hell no that's a good one
I'm just saying I like the reference um
the hipster answer is coming later
number 2 Walter Jones ok hipsters number
1 yeah Walter does a very active on
social media
I love Walter Jones who's your number
one Kenny easily that's Wow
what is your your life I did a story a
long time ago but I to buy these um
these newspapers on eBay because they
were these beautiful hand-painted covers
of Seahawks players in the 80s that I
know this is awesome and they're just
gorgeous and it was called inside the
Seahawks and it was a like trade
publication you know and they're just
beautiful covers Jacob green just like
that I wanted to frame cuz I'm that
person and one day I was like flipping
through the stories and it was like
publisher can easily uh-huh like he was
on the team right right so then I
started looking into us I could started
calling the writers and stuff and
they're like yeah he published a
newspaper about the Seahawks while he
was on the Seahawks it's like a side
hustle and it turned out like a lot of
players in the 80s I guess had these
side jobs they were like Realtors or
whatever and he just loved publishing
and the person he made the editor of his
newspaper was a woman so I it took me
forever but because he's like truly off
until he got induction to the Hall of
Fame recently and he kind of was like
off the map and you know he had a bad
relationship with the team after being
traded there was like a whole thing
about it you can look up and so I
finally got to him and I interviewed him
this was years ago and I was like so you
had the students like we were talking
about it and we're talking about like
the 80s and usually the hardest-hitting
safety man you got to watch
his hits I think he's one of the best of
all time and then I asked I was like you
hired this woman he's like oh yeah he's
like yeah he said I found that like
mostly the women I interviewed knew more
than all the men and this [ __ ] a
football player in the 80s yeah and I
just so I've always I just kind of stand
for him and I love that reasoning that's
cool it's cool to think also about a
world in which all these players when
the salaries are lower had to have
enough side jobs yeah the guy remembers
I remember seeing a Sports Illustrated
article about Joe Montana highest-paid
NFL player at 3 million dollars a year
and you think about that era and it's
working crazy
all right so Kenny YZ I love that before
I get back to the woes again I was I
said this to you before that was very
jealous that you got to interview Aaron
Rodgers when you see all the people
online and they're debating Aaron or
they're talking about his personality
and they it always gets down to them
[ __ ] on his relationship with his
family I feel like it always gets taken
that point is a knock yeah
what did you see in your interpersonal
meetings with him that kind of because I
know that you stand for him a lot
because he seems like a great guy hardly
at the player and I stand from all the
time what did you learn that maybe you
didn't learn just as a human being about
him through that experience oh wow
interesting um or what is the poly I
know I there's so many like yeah what
are they I think that God there's like a
million a million things like he's very
easy to be around and I think he
probably he comes across as being a
little bit maybe in terms of portrayal
but also I think sometimes in interviews
you see like the very brief yes a little
bit persnickety but when he's relaxed
I'll tell you this when we did this
interview a long time ago but I really
distinctly remember was he spoke for a
couple hours last time got he got he
drove me to the photo shoot photo shop
he's like I'll Drive you cuz that's kind
of like I want to go and in the car he
was so visibly relaxed once it was
obvious I was not interviewing him
anymore
and was just like a normal super normal
dude and I think there are a lot of
athletes who we mistake sometimes
they're on camera like reticence or
maybe unfriendliness for personality
when it's a very it's very specific to
being on camera mmm yeah because people
like when there's a camera in your face
and there's lighting and there's someone
behind the camera and you know that
someone's asking you questions to get
certain answers that can then be put on
a quote card or tweeted out or in an
article that an entire article that gets
to do Stout into one response it's gonna
put you on edge and I think there's a
danger to being too on edge and I think
that sometimes he slipped into that for
sure and I think there's some there's a
lot of who are almost like hyper
vigilant or nervous and it's like not
everyone wants to you know you you're
not gonna be misrepresented you know but
I do think I haven't encountered a fair
amount of athletes who are nervous about
either being misrepresented or honestly
like just looking dumb which like most
humans are worried about looking dumb
when they're being interviewed or on
camera it's really I'm nervous about
looking dumb all the time are you
nervous right now
no Bruce Irvin Carolina's defensive
front
reminds me of the Super Bowl 2013
Seahawks whoa serious good yeah they're
one of your favorite team I really like
Carolina I'm not a hundred percent soul
on the offense it all comes down to that
yes yeah because that people who forget
I love saying people forget as the
beginning of a session for all people
people forget no but people really do
forget I say often do with Cam you know
but it's freaking awesome to be any last
season there was a moment when I had to
eat a lot of crow because the North
Turner his office was so much more
creative than I expected I [ __ ] on north
turner off see ya the the North core he
hired all of his like family never like
that and I'm like can we stop talking
about Norv Turner success with the 90
Cowboys when he gets hired in 2018 and
then he went out there in the beginning
of the year super dope
he ran the warren sharp office yes
and Biden's running backs early downs
cam was getting rid of the ball early
yeah the offensive line in part because
of the nature of the offense was much
better than anyone actually that was
supposed to be a terrible offensive line
Taylor moment was like really good right
so that said I do think if cam is
healthy you could see I think some
improvement there and but the DG more
was great you know Curtis Samuel had
some sparks throughout the year love to
see him getting us more creatively again
obviously McCaffrey broke out big but
man that defense like when I just start
obviously you know they went out and
added McCoy right switching to a
three-four witch McCoy's fine in that
scheme I'm like a little bit I don't
know why they're going to a three-four I
think it's like oh if I got McCoy and
Eilert lost Thomas Davis I'm not going
to put more linebackers in the fight
especially like came on short in
particular is so good at rushing from
the inside so like why are you gonna
switch scheme I had in Charlotte right
after it happened and I was looking up
statistics and when I realized was McCoy
for the first time in his career is not
gonna have to play like 800 snaps
because there's an actual rotation I
also looked back and realized this is
the best defensive tackle he's played
next to in six years since Clinton
McDonald that's the last time he had
someone last year was blowout being
Betsy so then I looked at this team I go
they go out there and they get the kid
from Florida status one pass rusher they
go out there and they get Bruce Irvin
and they have you know they still have a
few other guys I I read that today why
the hell are these I don't know I think
they want Shaq Bear in space like I I
don't Iike Lee doesn't really matter I
think scheme wise but I don't know but
regardless of the scheme changed that is
a stacked front seven yeah not a good
secondary no okay but not good and as
we've seen the front sevens can
sometimes mask a bad secondary bud you
sent me a list earlier of the teams that
you're very high on I I meant like like
more high maybe it in the consensus
gotcha
so you're very high on the Panthers you
are high on the Packers which I think
what they did to their defense this
offseason was unknown one of the best
all-around changes but when there's a
lot of wholesale changes I get worried
about that
season just gives a lot of times it
takes a little bit to gel but the
defensive front alone gets me mr. and
mr. Smith no nickname they'll be cute
that's pretty good yeah yeah I mean
you've still got obviously Clark and
Daniels up front they added rochonc Gary
I thought that was a reach but but I
think having a bunch of people in front
of him they don't need him to be the
great and now he could be that
spontaneous seven sack guy Adrian a
mouse in the back
Kyle Sacro Sacro Lee tore the [ __ ] out
of your seat yes last year moving on
Adrian Amos
best best free agent signing watch well
I like what they paid for him like
nothing yeah and there's iliyan like
obviously they got Alexander but there's
like a zillion of those cornerback save
draft everything I think this is a
really good you're right it's all these
pieces have to be put together the NFC
North I think is going to be the one
that makes all predictors look dumb no
because all four of those teams can win
the division and I'm including the Lions
of the Y I thought you're gonna say
three I was like right I was like right
there with you but for me it's I'm not
the biggest Patricia fan but I look at
what they've added a little bit on
defense and I was like my disapproving
I'm not I am always my dog makes one
like another dog what's like that's
pretty good I am always a little bit
higher than on Stafford than everybody
else I'm like Orlovsky because I know
our laughs cute last effort to and for
me it's if they can figure out how to
actually have a scheme instead of just
random I feel like the lines where last
two years have been randomly calling
plays yeah with no purpose there's no
rhyme or reason to it and if it were
somehow to click I think they're a
little bit talented but Minnesota Green
Bay and Chicago are all Super Bowl
contenders in my book and I I this is a
take that's probably gonna Bernie I
think people are over rating Chicago
right now talk about it I mean great
defenses progress and you're talking
about a great defense that you didn't
lose a ton of talent I do think the Amos
loss and by the way Brice Callahan
that's a big loss yeah sure under 80
fourth healthiest defense
NFL last year oh and by the way they
lost one of the most brilliant defensive
minds yeah I mean and that was a
complicated defense wherever he goes
success follows I'm high on that Denver
defense for that reason what you just
said about the Jacksonville excuse me
about Chicago's defense aggressive think
about how many people were like I'm
gonna draft Jacksonville's defense and
the sixth round of my fantasy draft and
this is the thing you realize oh right
that defense compensated for our
mediocre quarterback and unless that
quarterback takes us at what you mature
whiskey could okay he could unless he
does that though he's not gonna carry
the team to me the two teams that make
sense to regress in the NFC are the
Bears in the Rams the Rams that's Todd
no I'm not saying they're going to I'm
just saying that when I look at I have
to imagine that people are gonna take
all offseason look at Shaun McVeigh's
offense because there's like five guys
the NFL right now who are running a
similar scheme so to study the master
you're also learning all those are you
good at you mean okay yeah I'm just
suggesting today I'm like gearing up I'm
like rolling up my sleeves getting ready
to defend I also I'm getting a little
bit worried about Gurley right now I
also look at their offensive line and I
thought towards the end of the year that
thing was a mess and they've done
nothing this offseason to address the
interior offensive line and I looked at
the teams that had success against them
Chicago Philadelphia New Orleans all of
those teams had really big front fours
that they just said oh you want to run
side to side we're just gonna go
straight into your face what's up I was
about to look up the because I think
they're making some changes oh okay
who's playing center now off the top of
my head I forgot all right do you use
our lads
I do big our lads person their current
offensive line is left tackle Andrew
Whitworth he's amazing left guard Joseph
Noteboom Brian Allen at center Austin
Bly that right word he's good
and then Haven soon yes I think yes so
it was the interiors offensive that's
right crumpled and I also look at their
defense and I think it will probably
take a step back too so I think that we
are not going to see this
Rams offense this year there's just been
enough whispers you kind of agree with
me well I think everything was the same
yes but I think I don't
I think McVeigh is going to adjust and
evolve and I've been hearing things
whispers about like some stuff we might
see I don't think they're gonna come out
and run 11 on every single play again I
think I saw I was reading some tweets
where somebody was talking about how
they used a lot more 12 and 21 at the
end of the year and mixing it up they
saw success yeah well that's what
Charlie no I think yeah I think that
you're right about girly but I think
that they drafted my draft crush Terrell
Henderson out of Memphis who's just
obviously perfect for that outside zone
that they run across he's fantastic man
when they drafted him it was like
honestly like I was Jonathan sparks flew
that's my guy
see the thing is when you have a draft
crushing land somewhere like the Rams
you're like oh I'm so happy you know
poor Jonathan Abram no [ __ ] I get to
watch one Hard Knocks good personality
right I've decided you know this from
your financial background I'm trying to
buy low on in the box
safeties I feel like everyone's cell on
that stock that was such a weird pick to
when we were all over the place the
Abram thing because Karl Joseph was
supposed to be the in the Box safety he
was like there cam then they added like
it felt redundant to me for them to
draft him unless they've totally given
up on Joseph what I love about the
Raiders is they draft
he's chunky they draft a defensive end
that's not an elite guy at war they
drafted in the Box safety and a running
back in the first round like complete
and this is max I know it's so crazy I
do I like him as a player certainly I
just thought it was like a weird fit but
anyways back to the Rams yeah I think
the problem is we also aren't gonna see
any of it in preseason because they
don't you know McVeigh hides all of his
cards during preseason I think you're
pointing though about McVeigh where
people are gonna go like what I just
said people are gonna figure out McVeigh
and then your retort is McVeigh is gonna
completely adapt I believe that can be I
could be wrong but I just think some of
the town's they've added some of the
decisions I could see them using
Henderson and girly I can see them doing
using the tight ends a lot more really
athletic Titans yeah
Cooper Cups gonna be back
my god I arranged everything yes going
back and watching some of the Rams game
so I'm very fascinated with the Rams
offensive decline during that terrible
stretch last season and I've been you
know what happened inside offensive line
collapsing Goff struggling under
pressure but when you watch that and
then you compare it to early this season
like the absence of Cooper Cup Keenan
Reynolds just couldn't make bridge that
guy it was like a ripple effect right
because then they had to move everybody
and it was just catastrophic honestly so
assuming he's fine which I think he is
based on injury just getting him back
it's gonna be huge
you also have a team that I've been a
team and the Super Bowl you have the
Eagles as one of your teams I like I am
okay with being a fan I look at this
roster and I see everything
it's gorgeous I look at what I thought
were gonna be weaknesses their middle
line backing core and they go and they
get Zac Brown to match him up with my
[ __ ] another guy that's what's his
name Mina dammit nigel Bradham and I go
we got speed at linebacker they got a
lot of mixed bag parts but I think the
interesting thing about the secondary is
Rodney McCloud because this is a guy
that before he got hurt was part of the
reason they were going to go to the
Super Bowl
yeah and now all of a sudden are like oh
you got hurt and we don't talk about him
anymore
and if Carson Wentz can be what he was
during that MVP run like you're feeling
it too
no look the strength of the Eagles I've
always felt this is the lines in the
trenches that's when at last season they
started playing well it was it's not the
Nick Foles is anything special it's
those two lines started looking like the
Eagles lines and was destroying people
who are yeah that's when you know you're
stacked when you're drafting Jason
Peters successor that's the best is
you're a good ass team but a secondary I
saw some coals but the thing with the
Eagles by the way you know I was talking
about injury I think this is just off
the top my head I was looking at foot by
outsiders as adjusted games loss I think
they had the second most games lost it's
a good thing three it's the only time
that you want to be injured is after the
season when you look back and go we had
so many injuries a good team that was
civilly injured last season to me is
like a prime that I'm gonna put my money
I don't know what the over-under is on
them but I like that team I'd loved the
one steel yeah I love that they got to
Shawn back I mean other than the
secondary I don't really have any
concerns about this roster
I love the organization of the coach I
live there that question for the Eagles
to start the year is Brandon Brooks tore
his Achilles in the playoffs and so we
don't know when he's going to come back
if he comes back in nine months which is
how long that injury normally takes
that's week six now guard they're not as
deepest town tackle because you got
Peters and Dillard and Lane and and all
those guys but III get really excited
the other team that you had was the
Chargers and I think the Chargers are a
very good team my question about the
Chargers is in December where is Phillip
Rivers arm because that's what kind of
hit me last year was this team's great
this team's great and then all of a
sudden what's their ugly it dissipates
also the offensive line is the big
question on this team which they did not
know they did not address and the
offensive line cratered at the end of
our season they are counting on Forrest
lamp final make a leap yeah so but and
there's like this alarming lingering
rustling injury we're hearing about
that's very concerning
Russell Kuhn was on the seahawks yeah we
did a whoa big offseason a few weeks ago
where Russell o Kuhn wanted to be paid
in Bitcoin and now that you're fine
you're also a financial person this is
perfect I what my question was why does
he need to get paid right in Bitcoin why
not just buy Bitcoin I don't know he's
been tweeting a lot he Russell Kuhn is
like really intelligent and cool but he
has been tweeting so much about Bitcoin
and I don't know who he has Bitcoin
logos on his locker - he's trying to be
the face of Bitcoin so you're reacting
as though that's not a negotiated his
own contract is owning I like that until
he starts talking about getting paid and
Bickel
I know yeah I don't know man I guess I
was looking for some insight here from
the fight that's that's not neither a
war oh that's a
a head shake it's a no I'm concerned but
the rivers thing is yeah you know I
mentioned this field yes and our time on
our podcast about the Chargers and I
actually when I was going roster by
roster I was like this team is better
than the sheets they are just undeniably
a better football team when they played
the Patriots last year that's all people
[ __ ] said the whole week was
positioned by position well Chargers are
a better team yes I may have said that
okay we also point but I forgot that
they had no linebackers and we're thus
going to I I didn't anticipate they're
gonna play an old like 20 defensive
backs the entire freakin game they were
like hey this worked against the Ravens
with Lamar Jeff that was a rough one for
Anthony Lin man but but Denzil pyramids
back yes and then they they did make a
couple draft picks on defense that I
really like adding at early was it you
know they could finally got rid of
what's the name today yep and then Jerry
Tillery I like jelly to Jerry's they
needed another big guy up front my thing
is is if you're gonna go to Foxborough
in the playoffs and your defense
communicates a lot like you you need it
like a senior like that's why the Ravens
had success in Foxborough they didn't
rely on coaching there was no pre-snap
adjustments they were gonna do what they
were gonna do like how many times do we
see the Titans in Foxborough in the
playoffs and tom is rushing up to the
line the linebackers are running around
because they're just gonna if you
communicate they're gonna destroy you
yes tough to play there you need those
like veteran I mean so I feel adelphia
like you need a team where the defense
just knows each other my team that I
keep starting to throw in there as my
sleeper team is the Falcons because you
talked about the injury bug yes
destroyed the complete backbone of that
defense was just ripped out and I think
in a way because the defense took a huge
step back and the offensive line was
destroyed I keep saying that it was the
best Matt Ryan year that I've seen in a
long time
thank you this is my I'm Matt Ryan hive
I thought Matt Ryan was better last year
than he was to her in the 2015 I think
he is the most underrated quarterback in
the NFL right now I mean I was a hater
for a long time but last year I was
this man is mobile he's excellent yeah
he was an excellent by every statistical
measure every advanced metric he was a
very very good now very high he's got
some of the best weapons in the NFL sure
at this point maybe the best receiving
core maybe yeah what's his name the
Titan Hooper - took a real step forward
last year I have a 33% hardship concerns
about this offense I agree with you the
defense obviously the injury bug hit yes
but I still the past Russian man is like
deeply concerning because those draft
picks have not impact back I combined
Vick Tech that's also one person they're
both great but both not great and you
know a yes they're getting guys back I
thought they would target whether and
free agency the draft the pass rush and
they didn't as you may remember they
just went they drafted like 300
offensive linemen which I thought was
odd I know that the offensive line it is
sure I really thought they'd go out and
get someone and they really didn't so I
still have a lot of questions about the
defense but I think that offense is
gonna score like a zillion points a game
it's so funny that you said that about
to Karras McKinley because they're one
of the woes I was thinking about
bringing up it was like falcons d will
recapture physical style and it's like
to Karras McKinley looks leaner faster
and ready to pin his ears I love him I
want him to be good when you do that at
the draft yeah the greatest yeah like
Robert Quinn ready to pin ears back with
Cowboys this is the best time Robert
Quinn is on the Cowboys yeah I did not
got traded not gonna pretend like I knew
that and my favorite part about this
article is Rod Marinelli was talking
about him and Dexter Lawrence and he
called them
we've got racing lizards over there that
can play the run old military coaches
when they compare athletes to racing
lizards phenomena I Dexter Lawrence huh
I never know which Cowboys defense -
Marcus Lawrence or DeMarcus or its
pardon me okay I was gonna say I never
know which ones are suspended or active
so I trouble keeping track of them how
old is Robert Quinn it's gonna be
upsetting to me because it's gonna be
way younger than I think
Robert Quinn I know it's really funny as
this article talks about how they're
showing him Simeon rice footage because
he had more success the end of his
career he's 29 years old so he's right
at that cusp now in my mind he's like 39
he's one of those like college
basketball players that played for years
yeah he's so old in my head
and he's younger than me and that's
upsetting but good for the cowboys you
see the Panthers are the all-or-nothing
team this year so we get to see their
whole season last year oh I think you
meant like Frank's the Amazon sir yes
which I love yeah did can make those
really awkward women reporter comments
last year was that two years ago I think
it's been about it's been two years yes
that wasn't last year but I am I am
excited to see Cam Newton fighting his
shoulder injury so that we can really
see how bad it was like I really like it
sounds like it was awful yeah I think it
was not only awful but he was a gun
fairly criticized through some games
they drafted will Grier right yes God
you know there's gonna be some annoying
I got some insight today that with what
happened with the Cam Newton airplane
thing Oh hit me so apparently he missed
his flight okay so for people who don't
know yes this was the video that
circulated of Cam Newton offering $1,500
to a fellow passenger and coach for some
legroom Cam Newton wearing a beautiful
fedora sunglasses which that to me was
the strongest part of the video that Oh
cam doesn't just dress like this for
press conferences he dresses like this
on a transatlantic flight in coach
that's phenomenal
that's you're right because most people
are like sweatpants and cam is like no
I'm gonna wear three layers with an ass
like women in the 1950s who would like
dress up to go on the plane I mean for
goodness sakes it's travelling cam
should Rock a monocle at all times I
love it I do everything he wears the
capris how do you feel about the weather
guy that imitates him all the time
I don't enjoy him at my time not every
time a dance video comes out I'm the
only one not liking the video I'm okay
so cam has acknowledged this and I think
his first response was like I like as
long as he's not making fun of me and
that's kind of like how I like this is
kind of walking a line yeah I don't know
I mean whatever is I hope it makes me
feel like I don't love it if cam is cool
with it you know what what is a an NFL
take that you hear a lot that just
grinds your gears if there's any off the
top hear something going into this
season perhaps sure well aligned with
your former co-host Oh Sims yeah I don't
think a week he's having a not normal
one
what's so funny is really quick about
that like Sims does not understand the
internet so what I see people go he's
doing this for clicks he's not what he
thinks and that's and that's why it was
so funny on the Leba [ __ ] show was
people like oh he's doing this no it's
just naturally who he is
so the brady thing though so we had
radio at 9:00 and that's way too breeze
breeze at 10 I think that's yeah that's
that's really off but Brady at night the
funny thing is like I actually think
Brady's probably at five or six now and
I think it's funny to me that if he had
said that I don't think it's like those
that small difference in ranking really
drives people insane sure but some
people would be angry at me for even
saying sex right they'd be like he's the
best quarterback of all time he is the
piece simultaneously the best
quarterback of all time and not the best
quarterback in univille right now that's
aging is the thing that happens happens
that was so pure that was really like
that was a legitimate reaction like a
Pavlovian response it was you guys look
in your eye and I imagine like a sidearm
well I look at not okay I tried to
convince the 33% in our in our show's
Constitution to change our favorite
quarterback of all time or the best
score back we've ever seen is Aaron
Rodgers - Patrick mahomes and a lot of
them said to me how can we say mahomes
is the best quarterback of all time and
he's only played one year and my thing
is I've never seen anyone do what
Patrick mahomes did last year yeah and
so sure we can say it's only been one
year but also I've seen nothing to
believe that he won't do this again yeah
like if find out we're gonna find out
cuz no he'll know hon Sammy Watkins is
the number one wide receiver on that
roster carry I mean Kelsey there's a
Jimmy Walker I like what's named Michael
Michael yes the Georgia he's like fast
yes his name is Emmy CEO Ellie he's like
crazy fast I think you're right like a
four we call hard [ __ ] me Cole yes is
it Mecca Lee me cold I think it's Mack
there's a Korean alcoholic beverage
called Mecca Mecca Lee that's really
good but in any case that's the kind of
content you get on the meeting I'm show
featured lady well now I need Mecca Lee
it's like a sponsorship I know I'm
trying to get that like barkbox money
it's a if you're listening buck dark box
hit me up but um yeah Pat those aren't
good offensive lines still but those
aren't great weapons
I know and they gave money to Damian
Williams I think he's gonna be the guy
who was the only season but I don't know
man it's Kelsey's either the best or
second best hide in the NFL right but
it's gonna be more challenging this year
without Tyreke Oh for a few games who
knows home I think my thing though about
mahomes and the reason I'm so confident
is he played the Patriots twice and hung
up points on him both times yeah he
played against the Broncos at Mile High
and had nothing going with his offense
and he still found a way to get it done
yeah like guys always say well you know
the sophomore season they've got the
tape what tape him freaking like side
arming it through like a two-inch Colt
like
oh boy don't let him do that like
there's no altar all they're gonna do is
they're gonna look at the beginning of
the first Patriots game where Belichick
pressurized a lot and they faked it and
they dropped back and it's like oh you
don't think he's gonna prepare for that
all officer I think I feel like in that
process I don't remember if it was like
a stun or something didn't Hightower
like intercepted something yes right and
they do that and the people are like
well the Patriots you know are like had
a lot of success with focusing more on
coverage if I'm like it's the Patriots I
will say there is a direct and this was
part of the reason I was down in the
Rams the Patriots know how to take away
the number one thing you're trying to do
and I would say that there's a lot of
NFL teams that cannot for some reason
figure out what it is the other team
doesn't most don't actually after Bella
check shows you what to take away you do
it but Belichick is the greatest in-game
adjuster that we've ever seen and that
by the way yes he is the greatest that
the Super Bowl was a coaching
masterpiece beautiful but you can have
the most brilliant coach the NFL saying
hey you know while we play man I'll hear
let's play zone guys some coverages
whatever
let's [ __ ] you know stunts like crazy
over on a bear front I don't whatever
all these crazy planning but if you
don't have a defense second completely
change every [ __ ] thing they've run
right that's not easy to do it's easy to
point the Patriots like wow they're a
different team every game wow that's
amazing we should do that too it's like
no [ __ ] I should do my makeup like
Rihanna but like I'm not gonna look like
Rihanna I'd be pretty awesome I just
want to see what it would look like
though it would look strange it would
look like a child I really think I've
been diving back in sporadically to
Michael and Barney's book because he's
got a bunch of great chapters on Bill
Walsh and then I'll go bunch of great
chapters on Al Davis but the Belichick
stuff is so detailed and it he's the
only one that can do it because he is
able to communicate like there was a
whole chapter about facing the Ravens
and how they come at their offensive
lineman's knees and how Belichick would
spend all week teaching his defensive
lineman to go at their offensive linemen
the knees safely but that so the
offensive line could prepare for him
other teams aren't doing
yeah this is what we run and we run it
as well as we can
yeah it's it's kind of egoless in a way
they're illegal but it's cultural to
like Andrew Hawkins who a storm yeah now
in faux hawk um he I remember once was
on my podcast timing his time at the
patriot he's brief stint at the Patriots
which he has fun with you don't think
about being a Patriots legend and all
that but he talks about how like little
things like he would put his hands in
his pockets and he would get reamed out
and whatever and in his explanation it's
like okay once you standardize all of
that [ __ ] mm-hmm you don't think about
anything else but these tiny adjustments
we're discussing because everything else
is so standardized and so rigid but then
he talked about how much he did play
with McVeigh a bit and he was time.i
it's not like that at all and players
love it and it's great and it's like
this fun culture and they're great too
you know but you know we have someone
with sidewall nasira but like you know
but you know what's also but by the way
like what's a close ass game a couple
things go differently Jared Goff makes
that one deep all that pass interference
that apparently they're gonna call this
year right yeah football so dumb like
one thing changes it goes a different
way and we talk about these coaches like
wow the amount of like really inside
gambling experts that I've talked to
that have said we do not bet big money
on the NFL I think it's completely
unpredictable I know people that have it
in their contract that they're not
allowed to pick games because they
believe that their insight gets ruined
if they if they go like seven and five
and a week they're like that is not the
barometer of my football IQ I have a
thing called left go [ __ ] locks let
me just tell you because the
alliteration when I go over for in a
week I turn off my notifications because
it is a travesty my confidence is
when I go for now I comb right for their
necks it's the best left go lux yeah I
wanted to call it left goes Lucky
guesses how's Lenny doing he's good I
miss him whenever I'm away but um he's
doing well thriving you know enjoying
his stardom being in in commercials and
stuff do you like let's say you get and
paid a little bit extra from a
commercial and you know that he's
involved you like get him more treats he
lives like a goddamn king you could not
spoil that dog any more than he's
spoiled it's 90% of your Instagram
content I know yeah you know I little
bit I know I've been doing these like
musical pairings with him pretty good
thank you
yeah I try to put out put out quality
content for the many fans out there I'm
going through the the great notes that
David has given me for you mr. Engler
and I'm seeing so Mina I'm sure you get
this all the time but what do you think
it's like for me being a man working in
sports media yeah I know it's like being
a man and do you like do you like
getting asked that question like I feel
like that's like a Richard Deutsch thing
it's not original
it's literally every panel I've ever
been on and every it's why I feel like
the way to respect is to just talk about
the game to not always talk about you
know what it's like yeah exactly
we see all the [ __ ] mention no I
don't think it's like opened sometime
when I'm talking to women sometimes I do
talk about how I can't do things because
it's actually useful to have this
conversation but I don't know I guess
sometimes it's worth talking about
because I think yes we know but
sometimes people don't know the extent
of it and stuff so sometimes it's useful
to expose people to that I think but
always like why do you respond a troll
or like quote retweet I don't I do it
that often but I actually think
sometimes it's useful for people to see
like that's why I do it
no I'm like I'm making I have a I about
95 percent rule which is 95 percent of
the time that someone shits on you on
social media and you were
hey man you having a good day they will
apologize and they'll say they actually
like your work
now I know it's different from a woman's
perspective yeah cuz they're gonna come
back and go no I still think that you're
a little lost sure but mostly they just
want to be engaged with in any way and
so I that bums me out because I'm like
giving them I have one DM with this one
guy that he it literally got to the
point where he at one point went you
know what I take it back
I do I don't hope that your dad gets
AIDS and I and I was like and I went see
all the progress we're making
and in my fiance I was like why are you
engaging in this and I was like I'm a
little bored and like this guy is
hurting on the inside right now speaking
your font fiance yeah I you guys looked
great yeah Awards Thanks I said that
before the pod and you asked me to say
it again you look like celebrity I was
like who are these celebrities I follow
an Instagram I mostly follow my friends
but I guess I follow a couple of
a-listers it was the first time in my
life where people were coming up to me
and did they think you were like they
were like touching my jacket and stuff
and they were like hey man you look
great you did look great but you had
like a stylist credit woody oh the one
that came into my powder my stylist
that's my life oh right there I think
you have a cool style this style - yeah
thank you appreciate when you lived in
New York did you just wear black all the
time yeah I try to wear black less
because it doesn't look good on camera
especially because I'm like a pale
person and I'm not really interested in
changing that yeah I'm taking the
necessary efforts to do anything that I
probably should do and but you know I
mostly either I have like two wardrobes
like being on TV and just like being in
my house and the house wardrobe is
mostly sweat material do you have a
current player that you haven't had a
chance to interview that you really want
to right now that's a great question
Thanks
because you know my mind is like to me
need to go to like the famous guys like
I've interviewed DeSean but they're not
you're not the most interesting right
right and they've interviewed the Bennet
brothers right yes you've interviewed
Rogers before they were like did you
interview Ramsay - yeah yeah and now
he's not giving out the kids - any
better last like a week yeah
can I just say this he is and not
everyone I interview I say this about
and I we can share some off-camera
stories about he is a genuinely like
kind and like good person to be around
who treats people well hmm so his
interests you know my story had some
[ __ ] talk not it was more about kind of
like his upbringing and stuff yeah he
did should talk ronk a little and so
obviously that was aggravating stuff but
but I found him to be immensely like
generous and pleasant with me yeah which
is not always the case but I feel like
did you get a chance to interview
Marshawn I have never interviewed
Marshawn he's got to be up there for you
yeah he is and why would you approach
that take me if you're like sort of like
because I know when I'm gonna interview
someone I go what's the public
perception of them yeah and then what is
that the the kind of canal that I want
to focus on because I don't want to just
touch on the things that everyone else
has touched on yeah at the same point I
get through this all the time where I go
do I want to consume other articles
about him or do I want to go in with a
because I don't want to be swayed by
like other people's stories you know so
I've kind of a unique my job when I'm
doing the series is different because
I'm writing something versus and and
when you're writing something it's kind
of more about your focusing on something
in particular about them and you know
what that is and you kind of know you
have like a direction and there's kind
of an onus for that to be something
novel or something
so I often will go on thinking like
what's something about this person that
people don't know yet that I want to
know informed by the things we already
know
so with Lynch I suppose we do know a lot
about him at this point I think his
upbringing is pretty well known
yeah story the way he kind of I think we
seen him a lot doing things but
sometimes the difference between
watching someone on camera and hearing
what about what they're like off camera
what it's like to just be around them
and what their personality is like
he seems like so many when the lights
goes on he's gonna perform yes I find
him to be very I think he's performing
most of the time yeah when he's on so I
just kind of want to know what it's like
to be around him for a day when you
write an article and let's say like the
Aaron Rodgers one I know you did a lot
of set up about like your apartment
right and your dinner I usually have
pillows and stuff I've never written an
article like this how do you like let's
say you're observing because I love an
article start off and Aaron has a dark
corner with one picture are you just
like frantically writing things down are
you like taking mental notes or it's a
mixture I'll take pictures but usually
have my phone I mean we always do it
like Von Miller we were fishing and I
just took a lot of pictures and video
and stuff so I would remember things and
I remember that summer was like he was
negotiating his contract what ended up
being the most interesting part in that
story and this is a perfect example of
like difference being a written story
versus where things are being taped or
whatever is we were in a car he was
negotiated contract very much in the
press at the time and you know Vaughn at
the beginning of his career had all hear
like the drug test right in the
suspension and all that and then he had
this Super Bowl he won the Super Bowl
for the team dragged me across the
finish line and had this like charmed he
was like the Stars whatever but then the
Broncos in him gotten this kind of
public negotiation over his contract and
that was sort of the basis of the story
like okay here's this guy who's turned
[ __ ] around and now he's like should be
rewarded for it but he's having this
conflict and we were in a car going to
this lake to go fishing with his dad
would immediately fall asleep in the
back I remember that very much good
buddies dad vibes they're really cute
together
and he was very affable you know like
super fun-loving guy it's what you see
is what you get but I remember there was
a moment where he was on his phone again
this is kinda you don't get a camera I'm
sitting next to him and I see he's open
Twitter and Adam Schefter had just
broken the news that he had his team had
turned
a very big offer which again you know
where that's from of course the Broncos
yeah and so people like greedy you know
and he's on his phone I kinda look over
and he's searching for his own name on
Twitter and those are like the moments
when you're writing a piece we were like
oh wow this is like this is a person
who's experiencing this crazy thing and
like you and me he's very worried about
public perception and you see how that
sort of PR war and those things actually
affect these human beings and they often
they can lead them to make decisions
honestly I mean my the Darrelle Revis
story I wrote my big takeaway for him
was the reason he was able to be such a
master negotiator in such a mercenary
was he did not give a [ __ ] about
literally he was like I'm not gonna do
all negotiation yes but very few people
in this world are like that and
corporation truly like that to me this
youth cookies goalies a weirdo but John
always not checking the Broncos mentions
no you know but but Von Miller is
getting alert sir well John always PR
person isn't robably freaking out but
yeah like Darrelle Revis just didn't
care like the New York tabloids were
like calling him Eavis and you're just
like the 2009 hard knocks season's over
and and reeling huh he's like I don't
know he's like I went to the beach he's
like I don't really read he's like I
wanna reads article and it's the only
person I've ever read read written about
who I believe that when he never read it
no I think I saw him leave he was like
how did it go but he's smart he's very
smart he just doesn't care he was on
vacation by himself
I'm simultaneously jealous of those
people and then also just confounded how
they could exist like that it's a very
unusual and Adams you can imagine it
really helps if you're a [ __ ]
cornerback right because you can just
block things out and not care at all and
get burned next play I'm still jealous
that you got Rodgers but are you do you
have anything that's about to come out
soon uh not soon no okay okay
do you like oh how do you watch a
football game well what is your perfect
setup yeah so on Sundays I've got the
two screens laptop taking notes
sometimes to myself because during the
season with my podcast sometimes we'll
talk about so I kind of think about like
okay if I'm gonna talk about this team
next week to TVs or tea
computer screen uh to tease I'll excuse
me so two TVs are either them on a red
zone or do you pick two games that you
care about
usually a game and red zone okay I'm
just gonna give a warning to everybody
I'm really worried about NFL Stream
reddit this season because MBA MBA and
MMA reddit streams have both been
knocked down and now I'm looking at NFL
streams and that was a huge thing for
everybody out there do you need to go
soon no no no be just sorta okay so
we're gonna wrap it up but I'm so you do
you do two screens and then you're
taking notes yeah do you want anyone
else in the room with you ideally no but
I mean I you know tolerated I'm just
sure people like me and I'd love to
watch a game with you I watch the I
watched the Seahawks with friends cuz
what I watching Seattle way yeah friends
know what with fans no really would not
watch Eagles game with Eagles but I love
the you know the high-fives and stuff
come on come on Nigel and I'm like dude
dude I watch out of control are you
superstitious at all so superstitious so
screamy
what is your what's the last
superstitious thing that you did well in
the playoffs tell me what you know I'll
change everything the worst thing I do
is like so there's me and I'm changing
Jersey changing hats whatever the worst
thing is when I make other people change
stuff and honestly I can't remember told
this story but it's really shameful one
of the only like I don't fight a lot
with my husband but one of the fights I
remember is I made him leave because I
said he was causing bad luck I made him
leave her
that's incredible and he was not happy
with me my feelings family are Eagles
fans by the way
oh you married smart my fiancee now
leaves the room when the Eagles are on I
was for the Bears game I this is a
little bit too much information I was in
at this point socks underwear and I'm
holding on to one part of the couch and
the other because I reach back to like a
yawn or something like that and a good
play happened and I sat there in that
position and it was one of those things
are like she walked out and like looked
at
and went I think and I had no shame
there's a video my husband posted once
and it was like early and our relation
we got it forever but it was like years
ago and Seahawks game around Christmas
about his family's house and the
Seahawks score somehow he got this on
camera I have no idea and I'm wearing
like a Richard Sherman Jersey or
something and I go yeah you know I'm
like called the voila you know I'm like
screaming or whatever and the camera
turns around and his entire family is so
horf because they had never seen that
side of me it's like run on the dark
side coming out that could be like a
really popular meme or like an NFL
commercial yeah yeah that's awesome
all gonna end on this who are you gonna
pick right now to go to the Super Bowl
oh boy yeah both teams yes okay you're
gonna pull up the team's for you the
Patriots and soft
it really is man mmm yeah I'm really
regret that noise I made about Pat
mahomes but whatever and then the NFC is
tough it's a stacked we just talked
about the NSE North you get the Eagles
and Cowboys in the East you know what
[ __ ] I'll go with the Eagles I took the
same batch of yeah I picked the Saints
earlier but as I've done this exercise
of going roster through roster schedule
- schedule thinking about these teams
I've I think that division is actually
more up for grabs than people think
every other year of the Cowboys they go
we're healthy this year we're not last
year was a healthy year they have Amar'e
under contract negotiations ich dak so
there's a lot of ego and play right now
NFC East I don't know run away with it I
think that division is I love that I
want I like to end on a note for them of
something that they can take I'm sure
that you get this a lot like I do young
people that go how do I get to where you
are and I'm sure that you get this from
a lot of different perspectives you
don't need to give the keys to the city
okay but I'm curious what is something
about what we do that for all the young
people out there that want to do this is
just something that they could take and
it's like a
good a useful tool for them sure so I
used to be like pick up the phone learn
to be a reporter and I still think that
if that's what you want to do but if you
want to do this kind of thing more the
talking and the analysis pick a sport
and like learn it man like I spent so
much time studying for I like it's I
don't I don't know I don't really talk
about it a lot but like reading I listen
like listening to things reading books
about offenses it like I spend a lot of
time seems like other people yeah you
wouldn't know it by how it's done I've
sound generally or but like how casual
we are but like I said it I think
sometimes people underestimate how much
time you have to spend actually studying
teams yeah I think that's very fair I
think you know I hit this where I'll be
on my computer and I got nothing going
at that moment and I look up NFL
websites and I look at Ed stories and I
I click on all of them yeah and I'm just
kind of seeing oh that's interesting
what's going on Titan's camp right now
and you just pick it up because we might
be on a podcast two weeks later and the
Titans come up and I'm like I did see
that battle I read on the herald land I
read a lot team blogs too like here's
the thing if you're a fan us like a real
fan of an FL team you know more about
that team to me like just like I know
we're about the Seahawks than any
national right it's very hard to know
everything about 30 teams so I found
that like the best analysis is usually
by people who focused full-time team so
I I spent a lot of time like if I'm
gonna you know reading like if I'm gonna
learn about the Titans I'm reading
Titans writers is there anything you'd
like to say to josh Cashman he's gonna
be at my live podcast and yeah when is
that let me promote that I well it's
it's sold out sold out but it's fly 22nd
July 22nd but you'll be able to listen
to it if you download the meaning I'm
show download the mean a kind so the
best like Meena Kimes live in Seattle
Josh Cashman will be there he'll edit
together it Seahawks have the best
Twitter verse of any team do you
I I don't know if I'll say best I think
it's distinct it's so awesome
there's awesome parts of it yeah but all
right I've extended the end of this
podcast by 20 minutes meaning you're the
[ __ ] I appreciate you very much I think
it was very painfully obvious to
everybody that you know so much about
the NFL and it's been it's been fun to
watch and see you get involved more and
more different stuff and I don't know
you're the [ __ ]
take that Josh Casper they're done with
that don't ever use it
holla holla holla we'll see you guys
later Mena you're the best appreciate
you don't leave me hanging
[Music]